le président des états unis dans l'autre
choc veut construire un mur à la
frontière du mexique
les répercussions humanitaires de cette
barricade font l'objet d'un vif débat
aux états unis or ce mur aurait aussi
des impacts écologiques
[Musique]
c'était la promesse emblématique de la
campagne de dolce up à la maison blanche
ériger un mur d'une douzaine de mètres
de haut à la frontière du mexique pour
freiner l'immigration clandestine et
lutter contre le trafic de drogue
cinq jours après avoir pris le pouvoir
il a signé un décret autorisant la mise
en chantier du projet
la frontière entre les états unis et
mexique s'étire sur 3100 km elle
traverse des écosystèmes très
diversifiée à la fois unique et fragile
à l'ouest la frontière longe l'estuaire
du fleuve dit ouanna qui abrite près de
400 espèces d'oiseaux elle traverse
ensuite les montagnes des penguins ou de
petites populations de mouflons menacées
d'extinction trouvent refuge en arizona
elle s'est par l'immense désert de
sonora où vivent des espèces
emblématiques du sud des états unis
comme le cougar et legranger au coucou
le fameux vos bonheurs
plus à l'est la frontière traverse les
sky à l'aise ces montagnes sur l'habitat
de jaguar de tortue du désert et le
serpent à sonnette
la frontière poursuit sa route au
nouveau mexique et rejoint le texas où
elle côtoie la vallée du rio grande et
et ses milieux humides
si le projet du président trump se
concrétise sens aux espèces de vertébrés
menacé et 108 espèces d'oiseaux
migrateurs sont touchés c'est ce
qu'avance un rapport préliminaire
préparé par le ministère américain de la
faune en mai 2016 avant l'élection pour
construire le mur il faudra ouvrir des
routes et détruire des habitats naturels
certains des écosystèmes et jalonnent la
frontière sont déjà trois années sous la
présidence de george w bush
des barrières de tôle mais dont ont été
érigées certains segments vaut quelques
kilomètres d'autres sont beaucoup plus
lents une étude réalisée en arizona a
montré que le nombre de cougar et de
quoi qui a chuté à proximité des
barrières
un mur continue et plus haut pourrait
mener à la disparition de certaines
populations
on s'inquiète notamment pour les oslo on
en compte plus qu'une cinquantaine aux
états unis dans la vallée du rio grande
et au texas
empêcher ces félins de s'accoupler avec
leurs cousins du mexique provoquera une
perte de la diversité génétique au sein
de la population et rendra les animaux
plus vulnérables quand on ouvre grille
du mexique
il avait complètement disparu des états
unis depuis les années 1970
des biologistes les antennes vais en
captivité ils ont réintroduit en arizona
en 1998 ils sont aujourd'hui une
centaine de part et d'autre de la
frontière
les oiseaux pourraient aussi se buter au
mur la chevêchette brune qui nichent
dans le désert du sonora vol à très
basse altitude
seulement 1,4 m en moyenne legranger au
coucou même s'il peut voler préfère
courir au sol documenter des impacts
écologiques de ce mur n'est pas une
tâche facile
c'est une zone sous haute surveillance
et les scientifiques ne s'y sentent pas
à l'aise pour travailler
d'ailleurs certains biologistes par
souci de sécurité ont cessé leurs
recherches à la frontière mexicaine sans
observation exhaustive sur le terrain et
sera difficile de mesurer les
répercussions écologiques du mur